This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's a sweltering June morning in Basel, Switzerland. Trams roll through the streets. Some people get their first coffee, while others cool off in the Rhine. I'm coming up here to the Munsterplatz. This is the big cathedral in the square. That's for Porter and Basel resident, Gabe Bullard.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。这是瑞士巴塞尔一个闷热的六月早晨。电车穿过街道。有些人正在喝第一杯咖啡，而另一些人则在莱茵河中纳凉。我正走向明斯特广场。这是广场上的大教堂。这是为波特和巴塞尔居民盖比·布拉德准备的。
There's a group here of people in their traditional outfits. the dark pants, white shirts, suspenders with idle vise. But this isn't everyday Basel. Gabe is attending a celebration of Swiss folk music that happens every three years, called Jolterfest. Yotlerfest is what I imagine people outside of Switzerland think the country is like every day. It's like a snow globe idea of Switzerland. People are in their long-sleeved traditional clothes,
这里有一群穿着传统服装的人。深色裤子、白衬衫、带有装饰的背带。但这并不是平时的巴塞尔。盖比正在参加一个每三年举行一次的瑞士民间音乐庆典，名叫约德尔节（Jodlerfest）。约德尔节就是我所想象的瑞士以外的人们每天认为的那个国家的样子。这就像是一个关于瑞士的水晶球概念。人们穿着长袖的传统服装，
sitting at long wooden tables, eating meals that are mostly melted cheese, even though we're in a record heat wave. A couple times, I passed by one of those wood cutouts where you put your face through to take a photo. These are of a man and woman in traditional Swiss clothes out in the mountains. And everywhere I go, from every direction, I can hear yodling. Some people here have been yodling all their lives,
坐在长木桌旁，吃着大部分是融化奶酪的餐点，尽管我们正处于创纪录的热浪中。有好几次，我经过那些木制的人形立牌，你可以把脸伸进去拍照。这些立牌上画的是穿着传统瑞士服装在山里的男女。无论我走到哪里，从四面八方，我都能听到约德尔唱法。这里有些人一生都在唱约德尔，
like Anita Fuliger from Central Switzerland. Yeah, I'm a mountain girl. I have seven sister and brothers, and then we take yoddling and music for a hobby and family. Others are here to just bask in the sounds, like Francisco Morgan and Gabriela Santa Maria. I've always find it's very attractive, very beautiful, all that has to do with folklore. In any culture, folklore is like the best thing ever. Francisco and Gabriella live in the area, and I met them as they were walking between food stalls
比如来自瑞士中部的安妮塔·富利格。是的，我是个山里姑娘。我有七个兄弟姐妹，我们把约德尔和音乐当作一种爱好和家庭活动。其他人来这里只是为了沉浸在这些声音中，比如弗朗西斯科·摩根和加布里埃拉·圣玛丽亚。我一直觉得它非常有吸引力，非常美，所有与民俗有关的东西都是如此。在任何文化中，民俗都是最棒的东西。弗朗西斯科和加布里埃拉住在附近，我是在他们走在食品摊位之间时遇到他们的，
set up to look like mountain chalets. They'd just come from a yodeling class, their first time trying it. It was wonderful. Thank you so much. Yodlerfest is at its core, a celebration of an old and beloved folk tradition. Some of the melodies drifting out from the street corners and buildings are the same ones you could hear in a small mountain town,
这些摊位被布置得像山间小屋。他们刚从约德尔课出来，这是他们第一次尝试。这太棒了。非常感谢。约德尔节的核心是一个古老而受人喜爱的民间传统的庆典。从街角和建筑物中飘出的旋律，有些和你在几百年前的小山城里听到的旋律是一样的，
hundreds of years ago. But beyond Yodlerfest and the streets of Basel, Yodeling has had a much bigger and much more international arc, because in the early 19th century, yodeling broke containment. This very Swiss tradition escaped the Alps, traveled across the Atlantic, and helped define a quintessentially American style of music.
但除了约德尔节和巴塞尔的街道之外，约德尔唱法有着更大、更国际化的发展轨迹，因为在19世纪初，约德尔唱法突破了地域限制。这种非常瑞士的传统逃离了阿尔卑斯山，跨越了大西洋，并帮助定义了一种典型的美国音乐风格。
Most of us know what a yodel sounds like, but maybe not how it's made. That unmistakable sound of the yodel is the result of a physiological flip that happens inside the sense. singer's body. Yodel is a singing technique where we use the different registers. So for example, the head voice or the chest voice, and very typical for yodeling is to switch between that to yawr. Nadja Rass is one of the leading voices, metaphorically and literally, of Swiss yodeling today. The register switch is something that happens naturally, even accidentally, like if your voice
我们大多数人都知道约德尔唱法听起来是什么样的，但可能不知道它是如何发出的。那种标志性的约德尔声音是歌手体内生理翻转的结果。约德尔是一种唱歌技巧，我们使用不同的音域。例如，头声或胸声，而约德尔唱法非常典型的一点就是在两者之间切换。娜佳·拉斯是当今瑞士约德尔唱法在隐喻和字面意义上的领军人物之一。音域切换是一种自然发生，甚至是偶然发生的事情，比如如果你的声音
cracks while you're shouting. And people around the world have been making music with this vocal quirk for centuries. In Iran, it's called Tahrir singing. In Georgia, Krimanchuli. Within the Alps, different countries and even different valleys have their own unique versions of this singing. There's a classic Swiss yodel, which is markedly different than, say, an Austrian yodel. Despite what we know about its regional variations, the origins of the alpine yodel are shrouded in mountain mist. History is just a loose end. It's in the dark. We cannot say it goes back to this and that century because we don't have written documents about it. We don't have artifacts like with musical instruments. This is Janik Wei, a musicologist who has studied alpine music. He also plays is the Alphorn, you know the horns that the guys play in the Ricola commercials.
在喊叫时破音了。几个世纪以来，世界各地的人们一直用这种声乐怪癖来创作音乐。在伊朗，它被称为塔里尔（Tahrir）唱法。在格鲁吉亚，被称为克里曼楚里（Krimanchuli）。在阿尔卑斯山内，不同的国家甚至不同的山谷都有自己独特的这种唱法版本。有一种经典的瑞士约德尔唱法，它与奥地利的约德尔唱法明显不同。尽管我们了解它的区域差异，但阿尔卑斯约德尔唱法的起源却笼罩在山间的迷雾中。历史只是一个松散的线索。它在黑暗中。我们不能说它追溯到这个或那个世纪，因为我们没有关于它的书面文件。我们没有像乐器那样的文物。这是雅尼克·魏，一位研究阿尔卑斯音乐的音乐学家。他也演奏阿尔卑斯长号，你知道那种在利口乐广告里人们吹的长号。
Yannick says that some of the earliest yoddlers were probably cattle herders in the Alps. And one of the earliest possible references to yodeling is a document from around the year 400 that describes some Alpine singing as, quote, Yuulate Carmine Diaboli, which an Austrian folklorist in the 20th century translated as Toodle of a Devlish song. More reliable documentation picks up around the 16th century. century, when travelers through the Alps described a type of music unique to the region. In French, it would come to be known as Rondevaish, and in German, Kourain.
雅尼克说，最早的约德尔歌手很可能是阿尔卑斯山的牧牛人。关于约德尔唱法最早的可能参考资料之一是公元400年左右的一份文件，它将一些阿尔卑斯歌唱描述为“Yuulate Carmine Diaboli”，一位20世纪的奥地利民俗学家将其翻译为“魔鬼般的歌声”。更可靠的文献记录出现在16世纪左右，当时穿越阿尔卑斯山的旅行者描述了一种该地区特有的音乐。在法语中，它后来被称为“Rondevaish”，在德语中被称为“Kourain”。
In English, it's usually translated as cattle call, and this is sort of a name for a bunch of different music. Some of it yodeled, some of it sung maybe without yodeling, and some of it played on the alpine horn or on different instruments. The reason cattle herders were devilishly tootling up in the mountains is debated. Musicologists think yodeling could have been a way for those herders to communicate across long distances. So on the Alps, it was a very scarcely populated territory. If you were working on the mountains, herding animals, it was maybe a very lonely thing to do. And you needed something to communicate over distances, both to communicate to, to other people, that you are fine, that you are in good health, and so on, and also to call
在英语中，它通常被翻译为“牛叫声”（cattle call），这是一种对多种不同音乐的统称。其中一些是约德尔唱法，一些可能是不带约德尔唱法的歌唱，还有一些是用阿尔卑斯长号或不同乐器演奏的。牧牛人在山上发出魔鬼般的叫声的原因一直存在争议。音乐学家认为，约德尔唱法可能是那些牧民在长距离交流的一种方式。在阿尔卑斯山，这是一个人口非常稀少的地区。如果你在山上放牧动物，这可能是一件非常孤独的事情。你需要一些东西来跨越距离进行交流，既是为了告诉其他人你很好，身体健康等等，也是为了呼唤
cows and other animals. Another theory is that yodeling was part of religious ceremonies. For ritual purposes, for sort of, we could today say magic. And there's also the fact that it's just fun to yodel. Imagine, you're out, miles from your home with only the company of your herd. You can shout into the mountain air, and you're a little. echo answers back. For centuries, these yodels bounced around the Alps, entertaining lonely herders, maybe being sung in mountain taverns or around a family dinner table. But in the 1700s,
牛和其他动物。另一种理论是，约德尔唱法是宗教仪式的一部分。为了仪式目的，或者我们可以说为了某种魔法。还有一个事实是，唱约德尔本身就很有趣。想象一下，你离家几英里远，只有你的牛群陪伴。你可以对着山间的空气大喊，然后一点点回声会回应你。几个世纪以来，这些约德尔声在阿尔卑斯山间回荡，娱乐着孤独的牧民，也许在山间酒馆或家庭餐桌旁被传唱。但在18世纪，
a shift came that would help launch the yodel from a pastoral pastime into a global sensation. What that change looked like was a surge of interest from people who weren't herding cows. In the 18th and 19th centuries, European travelers were embarking on grand tours of the continent. Europe's young elite would drink wine, study art, and generally acquire a sense of worldliness to flaunt back home. Basically, a regency-era gap year. Popular destinations included Rome, Paris, and the snowy expanse of the Swiss Alps. And with wealthy foreigners arriving to take in the sights and sounds of Switzerland, Jordlers couldn't help but notice. It was also then an opportunity for people to make some money by people.
发生了一个转变，这将有助于将约德尔唱法从一种田园消遣推向全球轰动。这种变化表现为非牧牛人群体对它的兴趣激增。在18世纪和19世纪，欧洲旅行者开始进行欧洲大陆的壮游。欧洲的年轻精英们会喝葡萄酒、研究艺术，并普遍获得一种可以在家乡炫耀的世故感。基本上就是摄政时代的间隔年。热门目的地包括罗马、巴黎和白雪皑皑的瑞士阿尔卑斯山。随着富有的外国人来到这里欣赏瑞士的风景和声音，约德尔歌手们不禁注意到了这一点。这也是人们通过在
performing in touristic locations on the countryside, also on mountains. With tourism, yodeling transformed from a cattle call into a performance. Singers worked the yodel into songs, singing a verse and then yodeling a chorus, what's called a yodel-eatel-eat, compared to a natur-yodel done without lyrics. Performers also took some festive liberties. No true cattle herder would wear something special to sing to their cows. But these performance yoddlers wanted to lay it on. thick for the tourists. They put on their troch, the traditional folksy outfits, to play up the exoticism
乡村甚至山上的旅游景点表演来赚钱的机会。随着旅游业的发展，约德尔唱法从一种牛叫声转变为一种表演。歌手们将约德尔唱法融入歌曲中，唱一段歌词，然后唱一段约德尔副歌，这被称为“yodel-eatel-eat”，与不带歌词的自然约德尔唱法相比。表演者也采取了一些节日性的自由。没有真正的牧牛人会穿特别的衣服来给牛唱歌。但这些表演型约德尔歌手想在游客面前大做文章。他们穿上他们的传统民俗服装，以突出他们家乡的异国情调
of their homeland. Pretty soon, there were suspended yodlers at every turn. That also led to a backlash by the authorities, where there were too many of these beggars going around with a horn or just singing, well, it became a bit of annoying to the tourists. In his book A Tramp Abroad, Mark Twain writes about a hike in Switzerland, where he heard a shepherd yodeling. He gives us a shepherd yodeling. He gives the shepherd some money to keep singing. He does the same with another shepherd later on. And another. Then another. Eventually, Twain pays the locals to stop singing. He writes, there is somewhat too much of the yodeling in the Alps. Luckily, not everyone agreed with Mark Twain. Tourists to the Alps heard yodeling and were captivated. It was this otherworldly echoing sound, unlike anything
很快，到处都是背带约德尔歌手。这也导致了当局的抵制，因为有太多这样的乞丐带着号角或只是唱歌，嗯，这对游客来说变得有点烦人了。马克·吐温在他的书《浪迹海外》中写到了他在瑞士的一次徒步旅行，在那里他听到了一位牧羊人唱约德尔。他给了牧羊人一些钱让他继续唱。后来他又对另一位牧羊人做了同样的事。然后是另一个。再然后是另一个。最终，吐温付钱给当地人让他们停止唱歌。他写道，阿尔卑斯山的约德尔唱法实在太多了。幸运的是，并非所有人都同意马克·吐温的观点。去阿尔卑斯山的游客听到了约德尔唱法并被迷住了。这是一种超凡脱俗的回声，与他们听过的任何东西都不同，
they'd ever heard. Some people were so taken that they wanted to find a way to write down the yodel and bring it back with them. Unfortunately for them, yodeling was an oral tradition without any sheet music. We have really funny exchange of letters, you know, where somebody from the city in Zurich was asking his friend to deliver a notation
有些人被深深吸引，以至于他们想找到一种方法把约德尔唱法写下来并带回去。不幸的是，对他们来说，约德尔唱法是一种没有乐谱的口头传统。我们有非常有趣的信件往来，你知道，苏黎世城里的某个人要求他的朋友提供一份
of one of these cattle calls and said, you know, I've been trying so hard to get one. But if I ask the people here in the village for it, they just laugh at me, they just make fun of me. and when they're singing it goes on for an hour and how am I supposed to write that down? People did eventually figure out how to write down a yodel. And pretty soon, the sounds of the Alps drifted out into the wider world.
这些牛叫声之一的记谱，并说，你知道，我一直努力想得到一个。但如果我问村里的人，他们只是嘲笑我，他们只是取笑我。当他们唱的时候，它持续了一个小时，我该怎么把它写下来呢？人们最终确实弄清楚了如何写下约德尔唱法。很快，阿尔卑斯山的声音就飘向了更广阔的世界。
Yodling reached Switzerland's close neighbors in continental Europe and then further into the British Isles. But nowhere did it take hold more forcefully than across the ocean in the United States, where it was about to create a new, very American genre of music. music. Yodeling first reached the United States in the early 1800s when troops of European singers traveled across the Atlantic to perform for American audiences. They came with their special outfits and traditional songs, ready to delight the crowds with the exotic sounds of the Alps. It's worth noting this probably wouldn't have been the first time Americans were
约德尔唱法传到了瑞士在欧洲大陆的近邻，然后进一步传到了不列颠群岛。但它在海外的美国扎根最深，在那里它即将创造一种全新的、非常美国化的音乐流派。约德尔唱法在19世纪初首次传到美国，当时欧洲歌手团跨越大西洋来到美国观众面前表演。他们带着特殊的服装和传统歌曲，准备用阿尔卑斯山的异国情调来取悦人群。值得注意的是，这可能不是美国人第一次
hearing a vocal flip in music. Many people were already familiar with the field holler, a way of singing practiced by enslaved people working on farms and plants. representations in the South. Here is an example recorded in 1939, performed by Thomas J. Marshall. But this distinct Alpine style of yodling took off in part because European yodlers were offering a performance, a costumed spectacle. And before long, Swiss, German, and Austrian yodlers became a fixture of the American entertainment landscape. American imitators also jumped on the bandwagon, and over the course of the 19th and early 20th centuries, yodeling became fully incorporated into the racial melting pot of American entertainment.
在音乐中听到声乐翻转。许多人已经熟悉了“田间呼喊”（field holler），这是南方农场和种植园里被奴役的人们所实践的一种歌唱方式。这是1939年录制的一个例子，由托马斯·J·马歇尔表演。但这种独特的阿尔卑斯式约德尔唱法之所以流行，部分原因是欧洲约德尔歌手提供了一种表演，一种装扮的奇观。不久之后，瑞士、德国和奥地利的约德尔歌手成为了美国娱乐景观中的固定节目。美国模仿者也加入了这一行列，在19世纪和20世纪初，约德尔唱法被完全纳入了美国娱乐的种族大熔炉中。
Yodling was everywhere. It became a staple of blackface minstrel shows. At the same time, white performers also imitated the field holler, and black musicians yodled on the vaudeville stage. The yodel was one influence of many being mixed and matched by American entertainers. Then a singing railroad brakeman from Mississippi came along and took the yodel to New Heights. Those are the dulcet tones of a man named Jimmy Rogers. Rogers grew up across the southern United States,
约德尔唱法无处不在。它成为了黑脸滑稽秀的主要内容。与此同时，白人表演者也模仿田间呼喊，黑人音乐家也在杂耍舞台上唱约德尔。约德尔唱法是美国艺人混合搭配的众多影响之一。然后，一位来自密西西比州的唱歌铁路制动员出现了，并将约德尔唱法带到了新的高度。那些是一个名叫吉米·罗杰斯的人的甜美音调。罗杰斯在整个美国南部长大，
working on the railroad and playing music whenever he could. At the time, Rogers perceived of himself just as a popular entertainer. He listened to everything he could get his hands on. He toured with different groups. He was always willing to perform if someone was willing to pay him. Jasselan Neal is a professor and historian who focuses on American popular music. She says he was a savvy entertainer with an ear for whatever might get an audience. He played what was called at the time hillbilly music, a catch-all term for music from the
在铁路工作，只要有机会就演奏音乐。当时，罗杰斯认为自己只是一个受欢迎的艺人。他听他能接触到的所有东西。他与不同的团体一起巡演。只要有人愿意付钱，他总是愿意表演。贾塞兰·尼尔是一位专注于美国流行音乐的教授和历史学家。她说他是一位精明的艺人，对任何能吸引观众的东西都有敏锐的听觉。他演奏当时所谓的“乡巴佬音乐”（hillbilly music），这是一个对来自
white working class South. But he also heard folk and blues music while traveling around. He picked up work songs from black colleagues on the railroad. He played medicine shows and minstrel shows. He had a stint with a jazz band and later a string band. Jimmy was a jack of all trades and in 1927 he went into a recording studio and and laid down something unexpected. An original song he'd been working on called Tea for Texas. You can really hear the blues influence. This is the style of music Rogers would have heard
白人南方工人阶级的音乐的统称。但他在四处旅行时也听到了民间音乐和蓝调音乐。他从铁路上的黑人同事那里学到了劳动歌曲。他在医药秀和滑稽秀中表演。他曾在爵士乐队待过一段时间，后来又加入了一个弦乐队。吉米是一个多面手，1927年他走进录音室，录制了一些意想不到的东西。一首他一直在创作的原创歌曲，名叫《T for Texas》。你真的能听到蓝调的影响。这就是罗杰斯听到的音乐风格，
played mostly by black musicians all through the South. The songs themselves that Jimmy Rogers is recording are very much in what we would call a blues form. They use the rhymed couplets. They use the use of a refrain. They come with the same chord progressions. Now, he modified them here and there, but again, a regular listener on the street could listen to this and say,
主要是由黑人音乐家在整个南方演奏的。吉米·罗杰斯录制的这些歌曲本身非常符合我们所说的蓝调形式。它们使用押韵的对句。它们使用副歌。它们带有相同的和弦进行。现在，他在这里和那里修改了它们，但同样，街上的普通听众可以听这个并说，
oh, yeah, I hear the blues form in there. I hear a 12-bar blues chord progression. So that blues song form was present, and the yodel was added into it. Rogers never explained where he got his yodling. He surely heard all types of head chest register flips, including from black yoddlers on vaudeville stages. But his style traces traces back.
“哦，是的，我听到了里面的蓝调形式。我听到了12小节的蓝调和弦进行。”所以那种蓝调歌曲形式是存在的，而约德尔唱法被添加到了其中。罗杰斯从未解释过他的约德尔唱法是从哪里来的。他肯定听过各种类型的头胸音域翻转，包括来自杂耍舞台上的黑人约德尔歌手。但他的风格可以追溯到
back to alpine singers. I'm pretty sure from having listened to a bunch of the source material that Jimmy Rogers was borrowing a vaudeville stylized performance technique that is absolutely linked to Tyrolian yodling and is a European import. When Jimmy Rogers recorded an alpine yodel over a 12-bar blues progression, he set off a chemical reaction in the music industry. His sound wasn't quite the blues or the standard hillbilly music of the time, or anything else. It was what we would now call
阿尔卑斯歌手。在听了一堆原始素材后，我非常确定吉米·罗杰斯借用了一种杂耍风格的表演技巧，这绝对与蒂罗尔约德尔唱法有关，是一种欧洲进口产品。当吉米·罗杰斯在12小节蓝调进行上录制阿尔卑斯约德尔唱法时，他在音乐产业中引发了一场化学反应。他的声音既不是蓝调，也不是当时标准的乡巴佬音乐，或其他任何东西。这就是我们现在所说的
country. And people loved it. It absolutely was astonishing how popular this music was. He caught the attention of a broad population of people who were really connected to his music in a way that I think it's very hard
乡村音乐。人们喜欢它。这种音乐的受欢迎程度绝对令人震惊。他吸引了广大人群的注意，他们以一种我认为很难的方式与他的音乐产生了联系，
for a regular listener today to think. We'd have to think about a superstar today at the level of global attention to match what Jimmy Rogers was able to do with the American population as a vernacular performer in the late 1920s. The stories that we hear are that people would literally go down to their local store, their local general store to get their daily supplies and a Jimmy Rogers record, whatever had come out. Rogers wasn't the very first to combine blues and yodling.
对于今天的普通听众来说很难想象。我们必须想到今天一位在全球关注度上能与吉米·罗杰斯在1920年代末作为一名本土表演者在美国人口中所能做到的相媲美的超级巨星。我们听到的故事是，人们真的会去当地的商店，当地的杂货店购买他们的日常用品和一张吉米·罗杰斯的唱片，无论出了什么。罗杰斯并不是第一个将蓝调和约德尔唱法结合起来的人。
The idea had already been percolating for a while, and a black composer named Clarence Williams had written a song called Yodeling Blues earlier in the 20s. But Jimmy Rogers was the first one to turn that comment. combination into a commercial hit. Today, Jimmy Rogers is known as the father of country music. Rogers sits alongside a very few number of artists like the Carter family who pioneered the genre by blending all sorts of American influences. Blues, field hollering, old British and Irish folk songs, and Roger's thing was his yodel.
这个想法已经酝酿了一段时间，一位名叫克拉伦斯·威廉姆斯的黑人作曲家在20年代初写了一首名为《约德尔蓝调》的歌。但吉米·罗杰斯是第一个将这种组合变成商业热门的人。今天，吉米·罗杰斯被称为乡村音乐之父。罗杰斯与卡特家族等极少数艺术家并列，他们通过融合各种美国影响开创了这一流派。蓝调、田间呼喊、古老的英国和爱尔兰民歌，而罗杰斯的标志就是他的约德尔唱法。
Roger's producer called his first big hit, T for Texas, a blue yodel. And that was just Blue Yodel number one. Rogers would record a dozen more, including one with Lewis Armstrong on trumpet. Other performers wanted to do what was popular, and Jimmy Rogers was popular. So before long, Yoteling was all over the proto-country scene. Lots of hillbilly artists used the yodel, finding all sorts of ways to catch people's attention. Like Mary Jane and Carolyn DeZerick, sisters from Minnesota who became popular on the radio in the 1930s. While the Dzeric sisters were doing that, Gene Autry was yodeling his way into Hollywood.
罗杰斯的制作人称他的第一首大热歌曲《T for Texas》为“蓝调约德尔”。那只是《蓝调约德尔第一号》。罗杰斯后来又录制了十几首，包括一首与路易斯·阿姆斯特朗合奏小号的。其他表演者想做受欢迎的事情，而吉米·罗杰斯很受欢迎。所以不久之后，约德尔唱法就遍布了原始乡村音乐场景。许多乡巴佬艺术家使用了约德尔唱法，找到了各种各样吸引人们注意的方法。比如来自明尼苏达州的玛丽·简和卡罗琳·德泽里克姐妹，她们在1930年代的广播中变得很受欢迎。当德泽里克姐妹在做这些时，吉恩·奥特里正在用他的约德尔唱法进入好莱坞。
Autry became known as the singing cowboy, and the films he was in shaped the iconography of the West, with his big hat, his broken heart, and his rhinestone suit. Get this, rhinestones have an alpine origin too. The name refers to clear stones that were found in the Rhine River, which originates in Switzerland. The word was applied to glass and plastic beads later on. There's not as much alpine-style yodeling in modern country music compared to the music made in the 20s and 30s. But what has carried over is the head chest register flip. That little flip, heard in the yodel and the field holler, remains an essential part of a country musician's repertoire.
奥特里被称为“歌唱牛仔”，他出演的电影塑造了西部的肖像，他戴着大帽子，有着破碎的心，穿着水钻西装。听着，水钻也有阿尔卑斯起源。这个名字指的是在莱茵河中发现的透明石头，莱茵河起源于瑞士。这个词后来被应用于玻璃和塑料珠子。现代乡村音乐中没有像20、30年代制作的音乐那样多的阿尔卑斯式约德尔唱法。但保留下来的是头胸音域翻转。那种在约德尔唱法和田间呼喊中听到的轻微翻转，仍然是乡村音乐家曲目中不可或缺的一部分。
It conveys the emotion of a lonesome cowboy, borrowing some of that heartbreaking pastoral quality of the mountains. For example, with Hank Williams' version of the song Lovesick Blues. I got a feeling of the blues. Oh, Lord, since my baby said goodbye. In that song, he uses a vocal break where he sings a word. And then he splits his voice across his vocal break up to a high register, comes back down and repeats that process in the middle of a word. So it's a little bit of a different technique than what Jimmy Rogers was doing.
它传达了孤独牛仔的情感，借用了山间那种令人心碎的田园品质。例如，汉克·威廉姆斯版本的歌曲《Lovesick Blues》。我有一种蓝调的感觉。哦，上帝，自从我的宝贝说再见。在那首歌中，他使用了一个声乐断裂，他唱一个词。然后他在他的声乐断裂处将声音分裂到高音域，再降下来，并在一个词的中间重复这个过程。所以这与吉米·罗杰斯所做的技巧有点不同。
But again, if we're taking that broader categorization of yodels as singing with multiple vocal registers, then Hank Williams is absolutely doing it. Today, the influence of yodeling has become so woven into the fabric of country music that most of us wouldn't even identify it as yodeling anymore. The vocal flip, the crying steel guitar, it just sounds like country. When you look at the dramatic evolution of yodeling in America, how it jumped from vaudeville performances to cowboy films and the world's biggest country stages, it seems a little odd that yodeling back in Switzerland often looks and sounds like it did in the 1800s, people in traditional outfits singing traditional songs, evoking a pastoral Swiss yesteryear. There's a reason today's Swiss yodeling still feels so traditional and nostalgic. In the 1940s, while Jean Autry was yodling in his rhinestone, Switzerland was having a very different experience.
但同样，如果我们采用将约德尔唱法定义为用多种声乐音域演唱的更广泛分类，那么汉克·威廉姆斯绝对是在这样做。今天，约德尔唱法的影响已经深深融入了乡村音乐的结构中，以至于我们大多数人甚至不再将其识别为约德尔唱法了。声乐翻转，哭泣的钢弦吉他，听起来就像乡村音乐。当你审视约德尔唱法在美国的戏剧性演变，它如何从杂耍表演跳跃到牛仔电影和世界上最大的乡村音乐舞台时，约德尔唱法在瑞士往往看起来和听起来像1800年代的样子，人们穿着传统服装唱着传统歌曲，唤起一种田园般的瑞士往昔，这似乎有点奇怪。今天的瑞士约德尔唱法仍然感觉如此传统和怀旧是有原因的。在1940年代，当吉恩·奥特里穿着他的水钻唱着约德尔时，瑞士正在经历一种非常不同的体验。
Europe was embroiled in the Second World War, and Switzerland wanted to avoid any association with Germany. One way to do this was to distinguish themselves as much as possible as different and separate from their Nazi neighbors. Here's Yannick Way again. Switzerland had this so-called geistigal Landesfurtiguan, this somewhat spiritual defense of the nation, where yodeling became important as something that distinguished Switzerland from its German-speaking neighbors,
欧洲卷入了第二次世界大战，瑞士希望避免与德国有任何联系。做到这一点的一种方法是尽可能地将自己与纳粹邻国区分开来，表现得不同且独立。这是雅尼克·魏再次发言。瑞士有这种所谓的“精神国土防御”（geistigal Landesfurtiguan），这种某种程度上对国家的精神防御，约德尔唱法作为一种将瑞士与其讲德语的邻国区分开来的东西变得很重要，
even though maybe from the musical tradition we're much closer than you think. The message was very much that we may speak German, but we are not Germans. Our yodel sounds nothing like their yodel. So please, for the love of God, leave us out of this. One weapon in this cultural defense was a yodling textbook published in 1943. That book is called Oh, Christ, okay.
即使从音乐传统上来说，我们可能比你想象的要亲近得多。传达的信息非常明确，我们可能说德语，但我们不是德国人。我们的约德尔声听起来一点也不像他们的约德尔声。所以看在上帝的份上，请把我们排除在外。这种文化防御中的一种武器是1943年出版的一本约德尔唱法教科书。那本书叫……哦，天哪，好吧。
Aingenurschencher Yodler Varban Shulung's Grundlanga for Yodlerin and un Yodler. Also known as the Swiss Yodeling Association Training Fundamentals for Yodeling Women
《瑞士约德尔协会约德尔女性和约德尔男性训练基础》（Aingenurschencher Yodler Varban Shulung's Grundlanga for Yodlerin and un Yodler）。
and Yodeling Men. The book, whose name I said before, perfectly, laid out some standards for Swiss Yodeling, not Bavarian Yodeling, not Austrian, just pure Swiss yodeling. It said which melodies to sing and which techniques to use. There's even like on one of the first page and says everything on Swiss in Yodling has to be eradicated.
这本书，我刚才完美地说了它的名字，制定了一些瑞士约德尔唱法的标准，不是巴伐利亚约德尔唱法，不是奥地利约德尔唱法，只是纯粹的瑞士约德尔唱法。它规定了唱哪些旋律以及使用哪些技巧。甚至在第一页上就说，瑞士约德尔唱法中的一切（外来影响）都必须根除。
In addition to the book, the Yodling Association put on contests where judges would favor certain types of yodels over others. And for many years, singers tended to stick to a textbook jury-approved set of melodies, sounds and flourishes. The Yodling Association did keep people yodeling, but this focus on a regulation Swiss style narrowed what had been a pretty diverse tradition, and the influence of these regulations and norms lasted long after the war was over. Still, you can't keep a good yodel down,
除了这本书，约德尔协会还举办比赛，评委们会偏爱某些类型的约德尔唱法而不是其他类型。多年来，歌手们倾向于坚持一套教科书式的、评审团批准的旋律、声音和装饰音。约德尔协会确实让人保持了约德尔唱法，但这种对规范化瑞士风格的关注缩小了曾经非常多样化的传统，而这些法规和规范的影响在战争结束后持续了很久。不过，你无法压制好的约德尔唱法，
and today Switzerland is enjoying a surge of interest in yodling, especially with younger generations, who want to play with a vocal technique that is, let's face it, Very fun. I talked to Nadia Rass about this at Yodlerfest. And one thing that has surprised me so far walking around is how many young people there are of yodeling. Yes, yes, yes. Is that a change you've seen recently?
今天瑞士正在享受约德尔唱法兴趣的激增，特别是年轻一代，他们想尝试一种说实话非常有趣的声乐技巧。我在约德尔节上和娜佳·拉斯谈到了这一点。到目前为止，走来走去让我感到惊讶的一件事是，有多少年轻人正在唱约德尔。是的，是的，是的。这是你最近看到的变化吗？
I think it's a change which developed since three, four, five years. So I think it's much the yodel community, it's much younger than five years before. What do you think that means for the future of yodling? This is a very good sign, of course. So I think, so it means that yodel will stay alive. Nadia has been part of this preservation. In 2018, students at the Hoksho-Lutzerne specifically requested a college-level yodeling program, and she was selected to run it.
我认为这是一个在三、四、五年内发展起来的变化。所以我认为约德尔社区比五年前年轻多了。你认为这对约德尔唱法的未来意味着什么？这当然是一个非常好的迹象。所以我认为，这意味着约德尔唱法将保持活力。娜佳一直是这种保护工作的一部分。2018年，卢塞恩高等音乐学院的学生专门要求开设大学水平的约德尔唱法课程，她被选中负责该课程。
The program isn't alpine cosplay. It honors the tradition of yodeling while pushing it forward. Students study the history of yodeling and what it sounded like before the rules and competitions and clubs. They listen to archival recordings, to American country songs, and they write and perform new yodels. On the day I visited, students put on a concert that included a song written by Nadia.
该项目不是阿尔卑斯角色扮演。它在推动约德尔唱法向前发展的同时尊重其传统。学生们学习约德尔唱法的历史，以及在规则、比赛和俱乐部出现之前它听起来是什么样的。他们听档案录音，听美国乡村歌曲，并创作和表演新的约德尔歌曲。在我访问的那天，学生们举办了一场音乐会，其中包括一首由娜佳创作的歌曲。
One alum of the program is Andrea Kutel, who's now yodling with her band Quartz. And she also blends yodeling with jazz, classical music, and other genres. I had the opportunity to yodel with the percussionist from Cuba. so it fits with other type of music as well. So it's really cool to interact with different types of music. The reinvention of yodeling doesn't stop with Nadja and her students.
该项目的一位校友是安德烈亚·库特尔，她现在和她的乐队Quartz一起唱约德尔。她还将约德尔唱法与爵士乐、古典音乐和其他流派融合在一起。我有机会与来自古巴的打击乐手一起唱约德尔。所以它也适合其他类型的音乐。所以与不同类型的音乐互动真的很酷。约德尔唱法的重塑并没有止步于娜佳和她的学生们。
For every traditional melody being honored and preserved in a Swiss yodling club, there's another young artist taking the yodel and doing something entirely different, like the Swiss Spanish artist called Vagamundos, who samples yodels in reggatone tracks. When I listened to Baillard Dembo When I listen to Vagamundoz, ... When I listened to Vagamundoz,
对于瑞士约德尔俱乐部中每一个被尊重和保护的传统旋律，都有另一位年轻艺术家在拿约德尔唱法做完全不同的事情，比如名叫Vagamundos的瑞士西班牙裔艺术家，他在雷鬼音乐曲目中采样约德尔声。当我听Baillard Dembo……当我听Vagamundoz时……当我听Vagamundoz时，
or Andrea's band Quartz, or any of these other new artists, I can't help but feel a sense of deja vu. Like what happened to yodeling in America might be happening now in Switzerland. Like Jimmy Rogers before them, Switzerland's new generation of yodlers is taking the yodel,
或者安德烈亚的乐队Quartz，或者任何这些其他的新艺术家，我忍不住有一种似曾相识的感觉。就像约德尔唱法在美国发生的事情现在可能正在瑞士发生。就像他们之前的吉米·罗杰斯一样，瑞士的新一代约德尔歌手正在拿约德尔唱法，
flipping it on its head, and possibly changing music forever. After the break, some of our favorite yodeling deep cuts. So Gabe, this story had some really amazing archival recordings, but there are also a lot of yodels that got left on the cutting room floor, and we wanted to play a few of them. Yes, as I was reporting the story, I got so fascinated by this era between when yodeling first came to the U.S.
将其颠覆，并可能永远改变音乐。休息之后，我们最喜欢的一些约德尔唱法深层剪辑。所以盖比，这个故事有一些非常棒的档案录音，但也有很多约德尔唱法被留在了剪辑室的地板上，我们想播放其中的一些。是的，我在报道这个故事时，对约德尔唱法首次传到美国到它最终进入乡村音乐之间的这段时期非常着迷。
and when it ended up in country music. And so these European yodlers, they came over like in the early 1800s. The blue yodel from Jimmy Rogers, that's 1927. So there's like a century of yodeling just kind of bouncing around America at the time. Totally, totally. Okay, let's learn more. Yeah, so this really blew my mind that the first known recordings of yodeling were made in the United States. This is something that Yannick, who we heard from in the story, was telling me.
所以这些欧洲约德尔歌手，他们大约在19世纪初过来。吉米·罗杰斯的蓝调约德尔，那是1927年。所以当时在美国有大约一个世纪的约德尔唱法在流传。完全正确，完全正确。好的，让我们了解更多。是的，这真的让我大吃一惊，已知的最早的约德尔唱法录音是在美国制作的。这是我们在故事中听到的雅尼克告诉我的事情。
And he sent me this. It's George P. Watson as the performer. And this is from the late 1890s. I'll find specialty with Iodo sung by Mr. George D. Watson Edison record. Well, so that was not recorded in Switzerland, but recorded in America. That is so amazing to me. Yeah, the very first recording of a yodel was from 1892, I believe, also made in the United States. But this one was definitely one of the earliest.
他发给我这个。表演者是乔治·P·沃森。这是1890年代末的。爱迪生唱片公司乔治·D·沃森先生演唱的约德尔特辑。好吧，所以那不是在瑞士录制的，而是在美国录制的。这对我来说太神奇了。是的，我相信约德尔唱法的第一次录音是在1892年，也是在美国制作的。但这绝对是最早的录音之一。
It makes sense on the one hand because the technology. was in the U.S. There were all these people yodeling and everything. But then also the Swiss experts I talked to were intrigued by this because we don't have an equivalent from the Alps at the time. Like there's sheet music maybe, but it's an oral tradition. It's evolving over time. And it's not captured at any kind of snapshot like that until we have an ability to record
一方面这说得通，因为技术在美国。有所有这些人在唱约德尔等等。但后来我交谈过的瑞士专家对此很感兴趣，因为我们当时在阿尔卑斯山没有同等的东西。比如可能有乐谱，但它是一种口头传统。它随着时间的推移而演变。在我们有能力录制它之前，它没有被捕捉到任何那样的快照，
it. So we don't really know what yodeling was sounding like anywhere else in the world at this time. That's amazing. So what other yodels do you have for me? So this next one comes from the 20th century when a lot of popular performers are sort of using the yodel as part of their toolkit. And this is from 1924. It's fascinating. It's a group called the seven musical magpies. And it's called the Calliope song because they're not just yodling, but they're imitating the Calliope, that big steam powered like circus pipe organ.
所以我们真的不知道当时世界其他地方的约德尔唱法听起来是什么样的。太神奇了。那么你还有什么其他的约德尔唱法给我吗？所以下一个来自20世纪，当时许多流行表演者都在某种程度上使用约德尔唱法作为他们工具箱的一部分。这是1924年的。这很迷人。这是一个名为“七只音乐喜鹊”的团体。它被称为《汽笛风琴之歌》（Calliope song），因为他们不仅在唱约德尔，而且在模仿汽笛风琴，那种大型蒸汽动力的马戏团管风琴。
I love that. Yeah. I really enjoy that one. I love that one of the big influences here is technology. Like the calliope was the sensation. Yeah, yeah, yeah. They're like beatboxing. You know, like they're like imitating the sound of an instrument.
我喜欢那个。是的。我真的很喜欢那个。我喜欢这里的一大影响是技术。就像汽笛风琴是一种轰动。是的，是的，是的。他们就像在口技表演。你知道，就像他们在模仿乐器的声音。
Yeah. Yeah, these singers, they think, you know what sounds like a calliope yodeling. Yeah, exactly. And that's some amazing vocal technique, which is also something that a lot of the Swiss yoddlers I talked to were really impressed by that they hear, you know, we heard the Zurich sisters, too, in the story. that they've heard some of these yodels and are impressed at the technique and everything, especially given, you know, these aren't people learning it from their, you know, from their families out in the Alps, you know, passing down from generation to generation. These are entertainers sort of doing what's popular, picking up the trade from others.
是的。是的，这些歌手，他们想，你知道什么听起来像汽笛风琴约德尔唱法。是的，完全正确。而且那是一些令人惊叹的声乐技巧，这也是我在故事中交谈过的许多瑞士约德尔歌手印象深刻的地方，他们听到，你知道，我们在故事中也听到了苏黎世姐妹，他们听过其中一些约德尔唱法，并对技巧等印象深刻，特别是考虑到，你知道，这些人不是从他们在阿尔卑斯山的家人那里学到的，你知道，代代相传。这些是艺人，在做流行的事情，从别人那里学到这门手艺。
And what about the other yodeling blues singers? Like you mentioned in the story that Jimmy Rogers was the first person, you know, to kind of hit it big combining blues and yodeling. But he wasn't the first to do it, right? Right. So Jimmy Rogers, you know, he has that sort of alpine-derived yodels, sung over blues chords. But that basic mix of blues and yodeling had been tested and recorded. There's the song I mentioned, the yodeling blues.
那其他约德尔蓝调歌手呢？就像你在故事中提到的吉米·罗杰斯是第一个将蓝调和约德尔唱法结合起来并大获成功的人。但他不是第一个这样做的人，对吧？对。所以吉米·罗杰斯，你知道，他有那种阿尔卑斯衍生出的约德尔唱法，在蓝调和弦上演唱。但蓝调和约德尔唱法的基本混合已经被测试和录制过了。有我提到的那首歌，《约德尔蓝调》。
It's written by Clarence Williams and it's sung by Sarah Martin and Eva Taylor. And it was recorded in the 20s. That's really nice. It's not quite as yodeling as some of the other. but I enjoy the tone of it. Yeah, it's not the full-on little old lady-hoo style, you know, that Jebby Rogers was doing, but it does have that melody of the yodel. And lyrically, the song is wistful and romantic, like a lot of these yodling songs.
它是由克拉伦斯·威廉姆斯写的，由莎拉·马丁和伊娃·泰勒演唱。它是在20年代录制的。那真的很好。它不像其他一些那样约德尔味十足，但我喜欢它的音调。是的，它不像吉米·罗杰斯所做的那种完全的老太太呼喊风格，但它确实有约德尔唱法的旋律。在歌词上，这首歌是忧郁和浪漫的，就像许多这些约德尔歌曲一样。
And that's something the yodel certainly evokes. The other thing that this song speaks to is an undercurrent throughout the history of country music, which is the erasure of the way black artists contributed to the origins of the genre. The seven musical magpies, Clarence Williams, Sarah Martin, Eva Taylor. these were all black artists and they're playing with the same influences as Jimmy Rogers. They're doing it earlier than him. But as the record industry built up, they were not the ones ultimately to profit from it. Yeah, it's another story that we hear over and over again across all of recorded music.
这也是约德尔唱法肯定会唤起的东西。这首歌所谈论的另一件事是贯穿乡村音乐历史的一股暗流，即黑人艺术家对该流派起源的贡献被抹杀了。“七只音乐喜鹊”、克拉伦斯·威廉姆斯、莎拉·马丁、伊娃·泰勒，这些都是黑人艺术家，他们演奏着与吉米·罗杰斯相同的影响。他们比他更早这样做。但随着唱片业的建立，他们最终并不是从中获利的人。是的，这是我们在所有录制音乐中一遍又一遍听到的另一个故事。
Well, this was so fascinating, Gabe. I love this tour through the yodel and these sort of leftover yodels on the cutting room floor. Such a fun story. Thank you for bringing it to us. Thanks a lot, Roman. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Gabe Bullard and edited by Kelly Prime. by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real with help from Mia Byrne and APM. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha.
好吧，这太迷人了，盖比。我喜欢这次约德尔唱法之旅以及剪辑室地板上那些剩下的约德尔唱法。真是个有趣的故事。谢谢你把它带给我们。非常感谢，罗曼。《99%隐形》本周由盖比·布拉德报道，凯利·普莱姆编辑。由马丁·冈萨雷斯制作，斯旺·里尔配乐，米娅·伯恩和APM协助。格雷厄姆·赫沙进行事实核查。
Special thanks this week to Linda Golden for interpretation help. Gabe actually has a new book called Against Convenience, which is out now. It's an exploration of the modern convenience culture, and I can't wait to read it. It is right up my alley and probably yours too. Cathy II is our executive producer. Kurt Kolsted is our digital director. Delaney Hall is a senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher John
本周特别感谢琳达·戈尔登提供的口译帮助。盖比实际上有一本新书叫《反对便利》（Against Convenience），现在已经出版了。这是对现代便利文化的探索，我迫不及待地想读它。它非常符合我的口味，可能也符合你的口味。凯西二世是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰
Vincent, Vivian Lay, Lashemaddon, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallin and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI. at 99 p.r.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
文森特、薇薇安·莱、拉舍姆·阿登、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔林和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99%隐形》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及《99PI》的每一集过往节目，网址是99p.r.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。